hello would welcome to this video so it
was I had a good run there and then one
out of six here this is not what you
want down to below 2400 after being
close to 2500 actually so it's really
something yeah I want to get back to
those rating levels okay Gordon and
English em young how to do the same
night a voice what I want to do I just
wonder if you for is a move for him
sometimes this is a tactical
biotechnical ADM that should be a
problem though
can even go 91 I cannot take this Queen
D 1 rupee one night takes a 4 so this
you form over there is a resource to to
look out for oh it's interesting tribe
and I can take on b6 now it's that's
rare actually that you get to take that
with the night often you have the option
to take that with them um with the
bishop okay I think I'll do it I think
I'll take them and now i'm going to
probably have to i will probably need to
take the default I just don't quite know
how exactly I probably like this and
nine to detune nice has a good spot on
see form black always has this pressure
here on e to this general structure is
believed to be quite okay for black
actually so I don't expect you to have a
huge advantage share anything but but I
like my chances in some endgame in games
IAM because of the pawn structure night
against dark squared bishop for example
is something that could easily be quite
nice for white okay so he's got b5
somewhat somewhat on the agenda move
like a four doesn't really do all that
much
he might play be five this is something
I have to take in order but it would not
help you see five bishop the question is
if I want to play Bishop f3 or not this
pressure is really am quite annoying
okay I'll do that little bit unsure
about this decision
because the bishop 1g2 is not all that
bad no that's that's actually nice for
me now i have before he cannot take it
because the queen is hanging that's
strategically extremely desirable for
white to get your phone I think you
should have taken on f3 this looks quite
nice yeah wonder ok I can even go F for
potentially to we not to attack but to
f4 here you have to have a 5 ready this
is so in case of like f5 i have e 5
and this is some a nice position for
white because black has very little
active ideas and most endings are
extremely good for white threatening g4
to force the Queen trade I'm between h5
now is an idea putting his queen into
some sort of pin yeah Queen h5 okay I
think he anticipated this idea however
however there are other ideas i can take
b7 even nothing particularly wrong with
it
quindi 5 is also interesting puts them
into a pin but he has Ruby 6 ok let's
just go for g2
ideas again G for now yeah I was
thinking I just together look at you two
queens you to this queen bee three
potentially at the end okay this is a
little bit of pudding Queen h5 though I
can play it cannot move the rook se8 is
hanging and I'm threatening Queen takes
h4 yes it should be fairly clear as now
he has to drag queens now we get
dimensioned ending now to a five or nine
thirty two words it's both pretty good
time morning yeah probably 32
check that is actually not all that
ideal he got he got selectivity looks it
too I got a lot more activity than
probably was necessary
and I'd come in to f3 though should
should be very good
Trent in traffic and soups it takes it
check check check check I think I rather
should not annoy to take this just be on
the safe side here god damn it with five
bloody seconds check check I won't
manage the shine boys check game crash
unbeliever and this is how you get down
from those high ratings you are not
winning an end game that like 30 seconds
on the clock which is really easy
you know he's come ended up here okay
let's do let's have a look I really
don't like those two two guys doing this
just completely irritating for a video
it's cool thing if you just want to look
at the game with the other guy but you
cannot do any coherent explanation if
they just put out loose and you're not
in dialogue with them mr. problem they
just enter whatever and it's not what
you want to tell so we have this this
opening line and the night before yet
the sentence is a little bit uncommon
that black allows the capture on v6 with
the night but okay this is a well-known
structure and usually as I said it's
it's considered to be a roughly equal
this kind of position okay and we had
this they decided to play with kev
through a bishop f3 which is debatable i
think rookie several is a huge mistake
and after this should take sandy for
wide is strategically a lot better
really a lot because i have four against
three now which is mobile my only
weakness is gone and this Bishop is
entirely useless so in this position is
extremely good for white and i mean the
the game basically approved that he had
a losing position basically check for a
long time yeah this ending yeah i want
all the pawns i just have to have to
wish a game ticket yeah she was chosen
to be confident but then I somehow
blundered he made some some weird boom
check what did he do so we had stuff
this as you can just take it of course
checked okay I'm in pre move mode and he
actually could have taken this which I
mean it's winning still but tricky and
now it was it irritated me so much that
cost like the the 56 seconds at
that I needed at the end I we had to go
back and together okay let's do it let's
be a thorough let's aim yeah and here
and German just don't have the time to
kill it off check no okay just just aged
Edam but I have one sec check to dupe
removes all the time queen bee to be
eight is actually made but yeah we know
you know how it how it works with it ok
guys thanks for watching